كلمه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
محافظه معي وبدانا بالحديث انا اذاك ولم
يتحدث سوى عن بولندا في الواقع في حديثه
حديث البابا بولس الثاني
واتحدث عن المكتبه في مكتبته هناك مكتب
وقال لي هل تريد ان تلتقط صوره معي قلت له
يا قداسه البابا انا اتمنى ذلك
وذهبنا بعد ذلك الى المكتب
امام المكتبه قال لي عضو مثل الشيوخ لا
تنسى
بانني كل ما حدثتك بشاني هو باسمي انا
يوحنا بولس وليس كبابا وبالتالي انا اتذكر
هذه الذكرى هذه القصه انا ارويها دائما
وهي كانت شخصيه مهمه بالنسبه لنا ان نكون
جنبا الى جنب لكي نبين لكم عن تصميمنا وان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هم بحاجه الى
امثال الثاني واخرين لا اعرف
من يستطيع ان يتجاوز ما قمنا به للامن في
اوروبا هذا امر ضروري جدا وهذا امر مهم
[موسيقى]
وبالتالي هذا له تداعياته في التاريخ
الحديث الامن في اوروبا هو امن ضروري جدا
وانا اتذكر التعليقات
التعليقات
والتزامات الامريكيه وحلفائها انذاك
فيما يتعلق
بالقوه وعندما تحدثنا في الماضي كنت اقول
دائما واقول دائما باننا فخورين بدعمنا
لاوكرانيا واقول دائما بانهم من الاهميه
بمكان
تريدون ان تجعلوا الحفظ الاصلي على شكل
التي فنلندا اما الامر الواقع حاليا انا
فنلندا اصبحت جزءا
من من الحلف الاطلسي نحن
نتقدم بطبيعه الحال ان ادعمكم على كل
مساعداتكم
لاوكرانيا
وعندما انظر الى هؤلاء الناس الذين
يجتازون الحدود النساء مع الاطفال وكنت
انظر الى
وجوه تلك الامهات وانا كنت افكر
بازواجهن
واطفالهن
وهؤلاء اعدادهم كثيره جدا الملايين من
الاوكرانيين الذين يتجاوزوا الحدود الذين
اجتازوا الحدود وبالتالي كان ينبغي ان يتم
وضعهم في مامن
وبطبيعه الحال في ان القياده
قياده قياده
هيئه الاركان الامريكيه ستكون في بولندا
وهذه ستكون
هل تكون امرا مهما من اجل ضمان الاجيال
القادمه السيد الرئيس
انا اود ان اكرر هنا بان العلاقات بين
الشعبين الامريكي والبولنديه هي علاقات
قويه وعندما كنت
شابا
تم
تعييني في احد المناصب في اذا عملته في من
سيلفانيا وكان لدي ايجار
اخذني احد الايام الى مدينه قريبه وفي تلك
المدينه كانوا يقولون البولنديون هم مثل
الايطاليين
واسمي كان لديه اسكاي في النهايه وكما ان
ترون من خلال هذه القصه بان هناك علاقات
هي محط فخر
وانا اقول بان البولنديون في التحدي
الامريكيه لديهم مشاعر انتماء قويه الى
بولندا وهذا الامر مهم جدا واذا جئتم الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سترون ذلك
وسترون ايضا في نفس الوقت التحديات التي
ينبغي لنا ان نواجهها معا ان نقوم بتطوير
شركاتنا وانواجهها هذه التحديات وانا سعيد
جدا بالعوده الى بلدكم اليوم وبان
ندخل في هذه المناقشات
ونحن سنذهب الى قاعه اخرى
وبطبيعه الحال العلاقات هي جوهريه ومهمه
بالنسبه الامريكيه شكرا لكم